emmanuel macron acceptera-t-il de
débattre avec ses adversaires à la
présidentielle en 2017 les candidats au
premier tour avait participé à un débat
le 20 mars sur tf1 ils étaient cinq et
le 4 avril sur bfm tv et ses news 11 à
une différence près le président sortant
françois hollande ne participait pas car
il n'était pas entré dans la course tout
d'abord il faudrait qu emmanuel macron
se déclare ou non candidat alors qu'il
ne reste qu'un peu plus de deux mois
avant le premier tour et si la lumière
n'est toujours pas faite sur ses
intentions le message est déjà passé au
sujet d'une éventuelle participation au
débat le figaro cite plusieurs sources
parmi les patrons de presse qui estime
qu'ils venaient le maquereau on n'a pas
très envie de se prêter au jeu qui
dimanche se fait autour de gabriel attal
le porte parole du gouvernement de
préciser le président a toujours montré
son intérêt pour la confrontation
d'idées mais à quoi ressemblerait ce
débat de premier tour
douze candidats cherchant pendant 1h50
leurs moments avec le président qui
aurait dix minutes pour leur répondre je
suis sceptique face à un tel format qui
montrerait surtout un manque d'exigence
démocratique
les français le savent on peut débattre
de bien des manières en 2022
débattre tout seul dans son coin sans se
confronter à ses rivaux voilà un concept
bien novateur peut être avec un live sur
zone dès story sondage sur instagram ou
encore un nouveau grand des 20 régions
cette réticence n'est bien sûr pas du
goût des candidats qui disent être
proche de l'obtention des 500 signatures
ou les avoir déjà obtenu c'est le cas de
valérie pécresse la candidate des
républicains qui demandent
solennellement je cite un débat il doit
rendre compte de son bilan qui est
calamiteux de l'état de notre école de
l'état de notre hôpital de l'état de
notre justice de la violence qui monte
dans les rues de l'immigration qui est
un contrôle et la démocratie moderne
aujourd'hui c'est accepter le débat
c'est accepter la contradiction on a une
présidence du mépris une présidence
hautaine distante et solitaire et le
président du rassemblement national
jordan bardella y va aussi de son
exhortation nous appelons emmanuel
macron à sortir de l'ambiguïté et à se
déclarer comme candidat qu'ils aient le
courage de descendre dans l'arène qu'ils
acceptent le débat et répondre de son
bilan quant à jean luc mélenchon le
leader insoumis il s'est emporté chez
cyril hanouna au sujet de l'impossible
débat vaqueront inclus une pagaille dans
ce pays et personne ne pourra lui
demander des comptes florian philippot
le candidat des patriotes nicolas dupont
aignan celui de debout la france ont
aussi demandé par voie de tweets une
participation aux débats il faut tout de
même noter que certains candidats ne
veulent pas débattre entre eux par
exemple marine le pen refuse de discuter
avec eric zemmour yannick jadot ne veut
pas de confrontation avec anne hidalgo
jean luc mélenchon quant à lui ne
souhaite pas échangé avec je cite les
nains de la gauche difficile de
rassembler ces personnalités
antagonistes sans canne ses tripes ou
concentre toute leur vindicte sur
emmanuel macron il faut rappeler
qu'aucun président en exercice n'a pour
le moment participer à cet exercice
télévisé au premier tour jacques chirac
ou nicolas sarkozy avait ainsi décliné
en leur temps mais l'époque a changé
alors de l'importance des réseaux
sociaux et après deux ans de pandémie
qui ont brouillé les cartes un tel débat
remettrait les compteurs à zéro il ne
serait pas qu'une aubaine pour les
candidats mais aussi pour les français
qui le demandent
le locataire de l'élysée consentira-t-il
à quitter les ordres de son bureau pour
affronter ses rivaux qui rêvent d'en
découdre
réponse dans quelques semaines